we're on track to hit the highest annual
average growth rate in over 13 years and
I will say this right down I'll say it
strongly as the trade deals come in one
by one we're going to go a lot higher
than these numbers and these are great
numbers now it's become a running theme
Trump defies the critics again and again
in the latest example well the fairly
stunning GDP numbers that dropped
earlier this morning but it was no
surprise to me like clockwork the media
are doing their level best to downplay
the great news one-quarter of growth
does not a transformed economy make as
as we all know the numbers bounce around
a lot from quarter to quarter it's good
to see but will it last yeah exactly
president Trump is gonna take a lot of
credit for these good numbers don't
believe him he's a lot of people who
bought things because they're worried
about his tariffs and a lot of false
growth from tax cuts juicing the economy
actually heard people saying it was all
Obama's economy hey it sound all of them
really excited about this chance for
more American success don't they well
here to react is the chairman of the
White House Council of Economic Advisers
Kevin Hassett
Kevin thanks for joining us tonight
thank you I know you're not surprised
what I knew this would happen this
number comes out after and we're gonna
play some of the great projeto
predictions from last year and these
immediate types do everything in their
power to downplay it or give credit to
President Obama it's stunning frankly
right I mean after President Trump it's
Laura Ingram's economy really right
because he pursued the policies that
you've been advocating for years and
years how long have we known each other
20 years 20 right 20 plants yeah and and
the fact is that we've said if we cut
corporate taxes then the jobs will come
home we've said that if we pursue energy
dominance then there'll be lots of
exploration and drilling and we said if
we pursued better trade deals by showing
that we're tough that we reduce the
trade deficit and so if you look at the
numbers that just came out we've got a
capital spending boom structures
investments skyrocketed because of all
the drilling and the trade deficit went
down
contributed to higher GDP growth and so
everything about the Trump agenda is
working and of course that's going to
drive the critics crazy and I'd like to
add one last thing I promised not to
filibuster that there can be a sugar
high in economics and so do you remember
cash for clunkers which was their
brilliant idea
first if you like oh yeah so they bought
a bunch of clunkers and then the people
had to go out and buy a new car and so
then GDP growth went up a lot in that
quarter but then after that they had a
new car and it went back down right and
so that was a sugar high what we see is
capital spending and capital spending
increases supply and so all of those
factories that are being built this
quarter are gonna produce output in the
next quarter and that output is going to
sustain the growth and that's what the
president talked about some of the
doubters Kevin are saying well a lot of
this has been juiced by other countries
buying our soybeans in anticipation of
the tariffs that are now not going to
happen at least as far as Europe goes so
they were stockpiling the soybeans there
was a huge increase in US exports of
soybeans just because there was a piling
and so then in other words they say in
the in the months coming these countries
won't need to buy as many soybeans
that's going to put downward pressure on
our GDP thus the four point one percent
very high level of today is not
sustainable going forward the president
said look for higher numbers today well
you know I I don't know higher numbers
but I don't want to disagree with the
president either but but the fact is
that you know we understand farmers and
the white house we know that the soybean
crop is you know about to be harvested
in September and prices have gone down
and in part they've gone down recently
because the Chinese did stockpile you
know lots of soybeans in anticipation of
a trade dispute and so that is true but
there are a lot of other things in the
trade data too like the reshoring of
activity because we're no longer an
unattractive tax environment but the
biggest news though the biggest news in
today's GDP report which i think is
going to frustrate the Democrats is this
old thing called inventories right and
so if everybody's decided they're
optimistic about the country they're
gonna go out and buy stuff then the
firm's will ratchet up their production
but if consumption is really really high
then they're gonna have to run down
their inventories because they're
selling stuff off the shelves right
because their production can't adjust so
fast and so inventory adjustments
subtracted
percent from GDP growth this quarter so
really we've turned into like jocks
business somehow tonight but apologize
but with the place that's 1% we're gonna
get back we're gonna get the 1% back
because they have to rebuild it like the
Shelf serenity that they gotta build
stuff for this I get it I gotta remind
everyone for some fun things fun things
here this is what Paul Krugman said this
was right after the 2016 election he
said we're very probably looking at a
global recession with no end in sight
I suppose we could get lucky somehow but
on economics as on everything else a
terrible thing has just happened May of
2017 LA Times
if Trump thinks he can get more than
three percent economic growth he is
dreaming and those are just you know the
ones we found in like five seconds in
our search today the critics are the and
Jeb Bush is about by the way saying that
yeah this is great because of the tax
cuts but you now have to do immigration
reform and you have to have free-trade
policies so he was he was kicking the
tariffs on the way on the way to the
praised there Kevin final final comments
well well the president's strong stance
on trade has delivered a lot of progress
in these negotiations on the trade deals
and remember the objective is to open up
European markets open up other markets
for agricultural products and other
products from the US and you saw the
really great news from the EU this week
that would never have happened if the
President had not bought for America's
workers and stood strong as you've been
advising the do never never never Kevin
thanks so much for joining really really
appreciate it